[Music]
we were with another powerhouse snide
Jennifer Lopez says she launched her
latest venture
but JLo couldn't escape being peppered
about her new flame Drake being spotted
overseas with someone else
your own competition at all
JLo ignored the questions about her
rumored man and the other woman who'd
raped was seen having dinner with on
Monday since this picture came out
dinner is supposed to plenty of her own
sexy shots oh is it a joke Drake what is
missing you are an expert at posing what
are some tips for getting that nice
little the booty pops I just try not to
look stupid out there you know what I
mean I'm just like keep your eyes open
keep your shoulders back you know well
smile too big don't smile too small our
Carly Steele was with JLo last night she
celebrated her new shoe line with
Giuseppe Zanotti the cool kicks cost
between nine hundred for these strappy
stilettos to three thousand for the
crystal booties JLo boldly modelled at
this photo shoot all the styles are
named after women and Jennifer's family
this is named for my little baby is it
about a gladiator snakeskin she's soft
and fierce the combination of everything
good in this world
wait so is this shoe and speaking of
fears well ever wonder what happened to
that a Grammy dress JLo
took the real thing out of her closet
where she keeps it and put it in last
night's window display what you remember
from setting foot in the carpet in that
iconic dress as I walked on like I felt
like an energy like everything started
stirring it was it was a weird feeling
around like what's happening my dress
was happening and I didn't know it
[Music]
you